on this week's show am I too young to
invest in property we give you behind
the scenes news from the eviction and
we're going to be answering all your
property related questions
welcome to the property investors
podcast thanks so much for tuning in
make sure you subscribe so you never
miss an upload you can catch us on Apple
podcasts Spotify and YouTube enjoy this
week's show and don't forget to share it
with all your friends
I almost Leeds I'm Alistair Cunningham
welcome to this week's property
investors podcast we've got a cracking
show lined up today we have yes I love
the way you're smiling already we're
going to be answering a really really
hot topic I get asked this a lot am I
too young to invest and fully a my team
- what was it - my own best in profit oh
yeah yeah you did you do it comes up
Lots because there's lots people come to
crash course there were only 16 17 in
the they think that they can't get
involved because they're too young and
how did you get on at the walk talk show
I'm just trying to see if you've got a
new watch on no not yet
no I'm well by one no no I only went
purely to watch some to watch somebody
else there's a little pun I'm working
with a guy at the minute to try and buy
me a couple of nice watches yep alright
explained what is a watch or well I'm
actually asked a stupid question I'll
alter this so watches so what I didn't
even know there was such a thing as a
watch auction near did I until a corner
and it made me aware of it but yeah they
were Sarah Connor Riley yeah he's a nice
guy
so he's just helped me I went to buy a
couple of nice watches but rare watches
as well like Rolex yeah they really like
this from the late seventies and yeah
brand new Rolex because they don't
appreciate the way all the ones do so
watch a good watches an investment
hundred percent investment so it's an
asset it's an asset absolutely about
pocket desert doesn't put money back but
grows an appreciation muscle you rent it
out you probably could actually rent it
out like you know para night per night
yeah so if you got a fancy duan yep
what hasn't Rena watch let's do a
jeweler we don't they
yes they are the high-end jewelers that
you can rent like a nice necklace or you
can absolutely when you know when you
all these like fancy events it see on TV
where all these women are done up in
nice dresses now mostly I rented for the
night or there are they're either rented
or they're gifted because the people
that design it want the publicity that
it brings them Wow
are you at that level yet no no rent it
I've got P you come up you can't try to
Rolex and go Rolex so friend give me a
watch I'll do is I'll sit like this on
the on the on the bottom and esther's
podcast and it'll be great publicity for
you yeah you know about well
interestingly a lot of people it's
neatly terrible actually for a podcast
it wouldn't be bad publicity because
considering we get fifty thousand sort
of use them like even a lot just listens
yeah so they wouldn't see it so it'd be
a waste of space well we can just tell
them this you will shake it could you
hear it this is a Calvin Klein Calvin
Klein's
does that mean it's a fake when I was at
Calvin Klein I just said Calvin Klein
yeah there was a D on the end of that I
don't believe there was was there a day
on the end it was Calvin Klein I know
you Alastair with addy but everything
has a day Calvin crumble they pay me for
this no probably not maybe they would if
we talk about it more maybe look more
product and rule Lakes is a nicer but
for instance right I'm sorry
if you want a proper for and get an
apple Sam so even he says apples are
rubbish yeah Samsung's I've Robbie to
keep them flat anyway and but like some
of these Rolexes like from seventies
they're that they're like worth seventy
nine thousand pound and they've grown up
very quickly Wow podcast don't buy
property by a 1970s
Rolex for me if I showed you them you
you there you there you'd love it you
don't even wear a watch and you don't
wear them no no you wear them on nice
occasions but you don't wear them
regular I wouldn't anyway because you
don't them getting damaged these watches
are perfection me so like they're from
the 70s but they've probably been worn
like a handful of times and they live in
a little box and they've got all the
paperwork see I can't help but thinking
what's the point
I'm not saying I was someone was saying
recently that there there aren't 2
passed away when they were clearing our
house they said this really posh
crockery okay in the stored away in the
cupboard and I said she's actually never
used it yeah
and she bought it for a special occasion
that special occasion never came it's
just like if you're gonna have something
enjoy it it's like why would if you had
a why would you buy a Ferrari engine
leave it sitting you garriage you want
to drive it you want to have fun with it
why would you buy a Rolex I'm not
wearing because it depends where you're
buying it for like it's you buying it
purely as an investment yeah then fair
and then so I the way I would do is I'd
buy it I would wear it no and again but
only for like I wouldn't wear it every
day a day today because they even though
they look at the way you're bouncing
your watch it's getting marked and
damaged and things that it still looks
nice doesn't it still looks nice I'm not
saying it doesn't so does it matter he's
done on purpose
no I bought this watch for Samuel for
his for his birthday okay why are you
wearing it right because I bought it no
blue for Christmas button for Christmas
and I was like hey bro because I he
wears a gold watch I was like what US
silver watch mm and he was like no it's
silver okay but surely you won't be a
varieties he's got two gold watches now
you got a silver one as well he's up at
Stella I was up all I really like it I
suppose if you hated that bad gives me
for my birthday and he was like my day
thanks anyway my birthday comes he
didn't give me anything about a month
after my birthday he goes oh oh yeah
crap watch that you bought makings like
there you go there's your birthday
huzzah just thanks mate
yup the Christmas papers gave me in the
box but hey ho you know I'm not I'm
bitter about it or anything anyway this
week's show
am I too young to invest in property
well I certainly am in Amin's I
certainly am NOT
and neither are you but it's a question
we get asked Lord's and you see lots of
comments on all the groups people asking
about one of the big ones is what advice
would you give for an 18 year old
wanting to invest in property my advice
would you give for a 19
to us in property advices anyone else
exactly what what restrictions have you
got as an 18 year old investing in
property what restrictions okay first of
all should we look at the negatives for
a young person look at the positives
okay so what what the negative is more
difficult to get a or so you can get
slightly more much level because you
need to be 21 as the last I heard from
the mortgage broker we use so you need
to sort of JV with somebody or you need
to have a source of funding but the
mortgages sigh probably a parent parent
a mortgage horse there is way samuel
done it so i'm going from 17 using a
mortgage host so that there's ways round
all and it my sort of feeling is if
you're gonna use age as a barrier then
you're already sort of on the back step
you need to forget your age and just
accept that doesn't matter what doesn't
matter what what comes because of your
age it's like any it's like any big
business decision right you make a
decision to do something and then you
work out how you're going to do it with
the circumstances that you're in so let
it for instance if you've got bad credit
but you still want to buy a house you
you buy you you you look at your house
and you see Luke this is where I'm at
I've got bad credit
I can't get a mortgage conventionally so
how can I get a mortgage simisage if
you're 18 you can't get mortgage how can
you get access to mortgage or how can
you fund that elsewhere at lease option
yeah there's all sorts because then you
not get in the actual mortgage for five
years time at which point you would be
21 listen one of the MMD the the
negative things I got get told a lot
from younger people is they feel that
they don't get taken seriously being so
young so John Ray Board had that he'd
mean John's 21 and he's a student and he
had the exact same things he felt he
wasn't getting taken seriously by estate
agents being so young I think that has a
lot about your presence yes well I I
proved that with John it was about his
presence because I we actually went out
he felt he wasn't getting taken
seriously by estate agents so I said
that come on I won't you for a day so we
were out for a day with him and I said
to him like you go in to the state agent
in to do what just do it do it how you
do it and you know John is a very
switched-on young man but he's a little
bit awkward and
some summer summer environments and then
i swell let him go in fast and then we
went to a station and I went in and I
said look just just follow my lead a
little bit and then we went we went to
another station and he was completely
different no he gets taken very
seriously I think I think the thing is
is often it's about how you see if you
think mm-hmm I'm not gonna get taken
seriously yeah yeah you're gonna go in
there and this is the same with anything
with you you thought mother taken
seriously gonna go in there with that
energy and that presence of feeling like
you're you you know maybe don't deserve
it or you're too young yeah and you can
you feel that and then if you feel it
there you feel it yeah absolutely and
like I remember the second time we went
in sort of enjoyment in the second time
the his whole mannerism was different
like he was very confident he was very
direct and to-the-point
mmm was the first time he was very sort
of sheepish and very beating around the
bush to get somewhere and I said just go
ahead be direct yeah take control of the
situation
don't let them lead you you lead them
well Samuelson interesting case cause he
got started at 17 he did a video
recently talking to a 19 year old about
advice and one of the things he said
which I thought was helped him when he
was that age he was young that was just
like at the time yet people like Justin
Bieber yeah who was 14 yeah who was
getting paid like millions and millions
of pounds on Wayne Rooney who was 16 and
people take them seriously yeah and
they've got the presence and that and
they don't think well they're just too
young because that they respect them for
what they can do not for their age yeah
and I think it's a it's if you yeah
that's true
the thing is age is just a number
because I know some very very
intelligent 18 to 21 year olds but I
also know some Complete Idiot's our
theory I know
Atos 36 complete don't do that it's dumb
37 oh I also know well this day so my
point being is the age doesn't matter if
you know what you're doing and you're
competent about it I don't think it's a
massive issue
I really don't so the first issue is is
is the confidence in yourself I don't
know we got remembers it's all about you
it's all about the VAT if you're ready
to do this don't you know don't
well don't worry about that and just
carry yourself with confidence and
you'll be fine next issue is obviously
the mortgage mm-hmm
it's been proven there's ways around
that yeah it's been proven so there's
ways around that you just have to get
creative where there's a will there's a
way
yeah if you really want it you'll get it
whatever negatives are there or is that
about it I think that's that's really
about it okay as a 16 year old you might
not have access to the funding that you
would not have access to for them like
credit so do rent around yeah you could
do rent to rent
I'm not sure in the legalities of our 16
year old entering into legal contracts
we just be 18 for that but so we do get
so it might be that you need to you can
be the driving force behind it but you
need to put it up with your dad but it
wasn't your mom or something like that
but you're the actual one doing it and
they're just allowing go back to Samuel
17 years old he couldn't legally say in
a contract cuz he's under 18 he didn't
have access to buy to let mortgages cuz
he's under 21 but he still bought a
house when he was 17 years old and I
believe we use mortgage horse who was
his mortgage horse I I wasn't his first
okay so I did what right for it so he's
had a mortgage horse so he got creative
and he made it work so it listen it all
depends on you if you want to make this
work age will not stop you if you do not
want to make it work and you can think
of any excuse then you'll always be
using age as an excuse hmm so I just
think get over yourself man up and just
crack on as Samuel said somebody left a
comment on the YouTube channel all of
they saying I'm 16 years old I really
want to come to the crash course but I'm
going to be really intimidated by people
out there because I'm so young I don't
have the confidence Samuel did you see
Samuels reply can we put it in there and
put it on the screen now so we're gonna
put the comment on basically the Samuel
said stop being a [ __ ] and get yourself
along the crash course simple as simple
as now they do have a massive advantage
yes people do okay
what if yours is different tomorrow what
do you think the mass advantages they're
so creative okay I think I think the
younger generation I saw the so much
more creative with things and they're
prepared to take much bigger risks well
that's kind of linked to mine pairs that
much bigger risk because they've got
nothing to lose
the thing is if you're almost the better
you're doing the more you've got to lose
yes if you let's say you were in a job
working 50 hours a week on a hundred
grands yeah and and then because of that
you've got a Range Rover
you've got expensive mortgage you've got
expensive - you spend your hundred grand
yeah
then you want to start you want to leave
that to go and do property or invest
money in that you've got you've got
something to lose
you can't you wanna leave a job you
haven't got time when you are well I
know but certainly when I was 16 17 I
had nothing to lose yeah if I went
bankrupt which is pretty much impossible
because I didn't have any money if I
went if I I'm just living at home well
let's face it what the the the age that
people move out the family home is now
getting higher and higher and higher so
I think the average age is like 25 years
old to actually leave the family home
how old were you
twenty-three twenty-two twenty-three it
was just for a start my first business
literally left bought a house and then
something first business and so lower on
the young side I was on the young side
yeah but the average age is I think it's
like 25 that people are living at home
longer so really what have they got to
lose nothing cuz I'm not going to lose
the house cuz let's face it and most
good parents are never gonna kick them
out do you find me in the north we I
would never kicked my children I don't
never look care how old they are they
can live there as far as I'm concerned
they've got a home there for life so I'm
even know what happens to them they're
never gonna not have somewhere to sleep
and not everyone's fortunate to have
that I appreciate that but most people
on the less you've got that I got that
when you're that age you've got very
very little to lose yeah and most like
eighteen years of not a crude day so
they've not they've not got debt have
they no no mobility he's not got
children once you've started going
children of family and people dependent
on you it suddenly changes everything
when you're just you and you've got
you've got at home even got even even
got anything you've got a pain do you
envy them Lord don't you envy some of
them they're 18 19 20 year-olds I've got
absolutely nothing - okay they've not
got massive perhaps massive incomes but
they've got nothing really to lose
that's a nice position to be in do you
not think we're your decisions really no
because I don't mean that what not what
I mean is just have been in that
situation we are you've not got 100 and
101 responsibilities like that's that
freedom that brings I've not having that
responsibilities I wouldn't gonna go I
wouldn't choose to go back to be honest
no I mean I liked it for me and I like
going through phases
I enjoy I've very much enjoy the journey
and right now I'm enjoying where I'm at
now so I'm enjoying that I'm enjoying
that the well I might if I was in a job
that I hated yeah and I felt trapped in
it was in the air probably I felt like I
had to provide but for me I thought you
know obviously love doing what I do and
I do - I'm just yeah I just don't you
mean that you know I mean to have that
no responsibilities in life is a you can
see why what people love it because it's
just so certainly wouldn't encourage any
I mean I got married at 19 so I moved
out when I was 19
well sama it's straight into it very
very very early I wouldn't encourage I
wouldn't encourage my I wouldn't
encourage mark I'd said to my kids yeah
enjoy while you got it and then move on
to the next thing and enjoy that you
know I had very little children I
enjoyed that now that a little bit older
3 & 4 you've gone past the baby stage
yeah and now I'm enjoying that I think
it's all about enjoying your life as you
go as it's been present and being where
you're out there enjoying where you're
at I agree with that more so in the last
18 months I've realized about being
being present yeah not worrying about
what's coming but also forgetting about
what's been and just actually living for
where you're at and what you want to
know ya know
you're not too young do get involved do
it if it doesn't work it doesn't matter
because you're 19 or 20 and what's the
worst that's gonna happen but the worst
you learn a lot you're gonna learn learn
study who wasn't it said and you never
fail you Neil and Anu so it is it's
never a failure if you see it you should
never see anything as a failure you
shouldn't ever see it as a learning
exercise so mr. Thomas an Edison Thomas
Edison with a bowl but he was told that
he failed like a thousand times
and he said nor didn't he was out of
thousand prototypes and I was a ball
both in this room that's probably 20 do
you know I mean unless there's a bulb in
every pretty much every room very true
very true
right it's now time for this
[Music]
I guess in the news this week we kind of
replaced the news we've just something
that's kind of trending yep which is the
eviction of the election hopefully you
guys been watching it if you haven't
we're it's a five-part series we are
three episodes in and the concept of the
show 13 candidates put in a castle
living with Samuel myself and Alastair
yep and we're putting them through all
its right as soon as The Apprentice so
those different tasks and then they get
evicted each week so episode want was
that was deal sourcing they have to go
out and find a dione and pass that on to
an investor do you know anyone that does
that well no that's BS isn't it yeah
okay yeah we do that and we do it fairly
well we have a we have a good system and
good team in place so I like being very
modest
yeah how do you think they got on with
that task well you should it okay so I I
had quite a good insight to that cuz I
remember being there and I remember it
for me
the the biggest sock up on that show was
when Ricky shook the hand of Trevor and
agreed to our 2000 bond refurb on
something that I said no no no that
should be at least six seven thousand
pound and then they were so keen to get
the deal that they're like yeah we will
drop the finder's fee to 1500 and with
the two grand reef our so what's the
lesson though just don't be a dead don't
be a more just don't be a motivated so
he was a motivated deal seller he was so
desperate to sell a deal that he saw cut
his nose off to spite his face now if
you seen episode two you'll see they all
come good in the end but that's not the
point the point being is if you did
multiple deals you cannot do that every
deal because how many deals do does he
get physically hands-on with you don't
do you that's not what it's about
so just be realistic at all times but in
fairness if you've seen episode two
you'll see that Ricky Steve Dyson Steve
Dyson and Elliot Powell Elliot Powell
which I do think Elliot Powell perhaps
shouldn't have got evicted but he did
the twirl I know we've done the twirl
we've kind of got a go just for the
maybe maybe Nick can put a little
little cutaway of that end just so you
can see that well I know that but I
actually don't think he was the weakest
Steve Dyson yeah I don't think he
contributed much at all to episode one
say it and who else I'm not gonna say
who else actually but I certainly don't
think it was Steven it needed to be
evicted I mean oh yeah yeah Steven
definitely evicted but I don't think was
I don't know Elliot should have gone
into the cash it was a little bit a lot
of thought James should have gone I I
saw yeah I tend to really on that okay
I'm just judging off by what people are
saying yeah I guess in episode 2 we have
they weren't expecting that were they
the other delegates the candidates if
we're not expecting will challenge so
they sell the dealing it's like all
right you've got going to the reefer for
the price that you promised see their
faces drop it was brilliant it was it
was interesting episode 2 it was very
much for me like episode 1
it was kind of quite close yeah it was
like who's gonna sell episode 2 it was
like okay well they're terrible and
they're awesome
yeah so the the Alicia's team Alicia was
team captain wasn't she
no ncnz was team captain and they by far
had the easiest job by a country mile
had the easiest job he had they courted
to refurbs are like a decent high-end
refurb and that was like four grand
summer and in are basically a liqueur
pain and a few carpets for eleven
hundred and seventy quit about the boys
the boys courted a top Henry foe with a
new kitchen for two thousand pound
Alistair is there on camera meant to be
meant to be motivating and help with him
he just he's literally I'll do my best
impression he goes a it's just like
you're screwed hope mate there's hope
and he just walks off when well
ultimately I'll oddly one the task they
actually failed in the refurb because
they didn't deliver what they said they
wouldn't deliver so Trevor Lee and wait
I did know that they they did the HMO to
a high standard yes but it didn't
deliver what they thought they were
but the alcohol yeah it doesn't matter
that's not what it wasn't done an
overall they had on an hour work an
agenda of works and they quoted this
they did not fulfill that agenda works
for what they did because the investor
was happy yeah father did listen they've
done a fantastic job
fantastic job the only thing that was
the like the the son did that they ended
the windowsill and he was a little bit
you know I know I know that and he was a
little bit disappointed that the kitchen
wasn't done but ultimately the kitchen
did look good I'm not sick I'm not taken
away from the guys they don't have an
amazing job an amazing job really really
good but the richly pulled it out at the
back oh my massively Ricky League right
um he screwed up tapes of one and he
pulled it back in Episode two
I'll tell you who else done well Antony
because he he's got a little bit
experience been hands-on and and he sort
of did it over the windrow yeah
absolutely and but in the end C's team
it was just chaos
mmm nobody knew what they were doing and
he was a pretty rubbish team leader to
be honest and she left you in home for
two days she's like say yeah I'm off and
she just left it is Kirsty went home
James went home Oh James went out and
got drunk with her he met met one of his
investors and went haven't got drunk yet
he survived again yeah he survived a
game what's that all about I did
surprise my surprised me because like
really any I don't think he actually
cared like so we were absolute - I
remember being in the boardroom and me
you and Sammy were discussing and like
teams doesn't do monkeys does he doesn't
care surprise doesn't even want to be
here and I really thought yeah I think
he does care just did surprise me that
and then episode three in all fairness
episode 3 is the worst the hardest
challenge yeah but they pulled that
gonna find no me down deals got like a
couple of days two and a half three days
to go and do it and oh my days they
don't pull them out of they were table
and when it says there's no money
there's no normally deals out there if
you've not seen already watch episode 3
because serious serious stuff I felt
I've seriously
serves to go we should go hundred
winners 100% I was I remember sat in the
boardroom and you've got this team of
done X Magnum no my daddy was in this
thing done the same amount of no money
down deals these ones were slightly
better yeah but they've all done
normally done deals divorce skewed lease
options on rent drains no money down low
words the team there will a phenomenal
they all done really real I couldn't
pick one person I thought lacked really
know who got evicted from the end of
that episode three so who got evicted
from episode to episode two was and
seriously Danny
for that wall because she painted that
wall didn't you and Kirstie I'm not
answering
Kirsty who you said to Kirsty Kirsty who
do you think should be evicted and she
was like yeah just an answer after about
10 seconds Sammy wait girls that you're
victors do you know I don't even know
what cost he thought I'm episode 2
because she's not cleaning it ok she
cleaned all the kitchen she worked hard
that she had worked hard yeah it was
funny when you were sure I'm gonna go
back to able to it was funny when you
were sure in their mid week around the
property and she was just disgusted
wouldn't you yeah and she's I want to
see them and you what what now it's yeah
wanna see him no you went outside house
you're comin out you're like she ain't
very happy the UN outside you said okay
so the investor wants to see and they're
all probably thinking oh she loves there
is it was awkward for me because I went
around the house and I thought it was
terrible yeah and then I've now got to
show mad reek around the house and try I
know it's terrible
alright and I know it's nothing like
what they're promised so I'm trying to
point out the good stuff some you know
floor oh it's so much better than the
floor before which is like well it's
bubbles here and I'm like and by the end
I kind of given up by the yeah
I was like yeah she's like it's not very
high and as I might know the bright
orange because it reminded over budget
air that's so funny
you know it was hideous was that it was
hideous but I thought they deserve to go
home and wash out in a bowl and what's
all that but it's not very professional
is it I'm surprised Abby didn't go I
really wanted Abby to be kicked out of
that
yeah I think she deserves to be kicked
out you don't argue with people at that
in business you don't shout and scream
in people's face at and there's been a
lot of comments on YouTube Roberta so
that I think there a ball has bad with
each other but absent Abey Abey started
blaming NZ for Shou in fast when it was
actually a pili show at first it was a
bee a bee raised her voice and then into
NC lost it so it weighs what is I think
it's very unprofessional I think bull
from actually should have been evicted
because of that yeah but it's very very
interesting but episode 3 well you might
not have seen that so we won't reveal
now it's not good too much DNA it's not
register but make sure you guys check it
out just search the eviction and you
know let put it on social media share it
give your opinion there is a hashtag for
it as a hashtag the eviction yeah
absolutely eviction right it's now time
for this so the first question is from
Ezra Ezra O'Malley and this is the
question and where are the top three
places to get a hater maybe for article
four starts there edits you guys are
awesome oh thanks man
Thank You Ezra so the math is three
though we can think of but somewhere
certainly one of the really hot areas at
the minute where Arctic for comes in
this year so you have to be quick donate
Doni Doni Doni
Doncaster Arctic fall comes in 2009
Tober this year hmm October 1st so you
have to be quick if you want to get
converting over there other areas I I'm
actively looking in there's no work for
a present I'm not sure I want to give
them away to be honest the purpose of
this show right I'll tell you I'll say
some good areas to be working out value
as possible I'll kademan I'll take some
good ears to be looking at them in it
Blackpool
you go and wrap that pool a lot you up
although yeah I think Blackpool is going
to explored in the next 10 years I think
it is a real hope so for the wrong
reasons but yeah there's a lots going on
there is lots going on at Blackpool
another area would be long eaten just I
said Nottingham because that attracts a
lot of people from Nottingham and
there's no article for and some of the
some of the areas are quite high end
look there some of the rentals are quite
good there you go so you heard it here
first long mate in Blackpool and donates
ok next question from Daniel Dodson
hello chaps love the show makes me laugh
every time I tune in
thanks man I'm also booked onto the deal
fighting Stravaganza I never use your
own money again
also Alistair's deal sourcing cut wow
you're on him and we love you almost his
name Daniel Dodson yes I know Daniel
he's coming to the mentoring starts in
two weeks but in the lead-up to those
while I practice are there any rule of
thumb when working out major medium and
light refurb cost or is it literally
just judge each one individually okay
we're going to cover this when you come
see me in a couple of weeks and the way
I would I always do it you can't there's
no such thing as a major minor where
ever it's all done with square footage
and what's what a refurb standard you're
looking at so we roll of thumb I imagine
you're you've got big thumbs I imagine
so magic so when you go and look at
property I would for the first couple
times take something who knows what
they're doing with you I who knows how
to look at property and also a price
stuff up for instance I used to think a
builder with me I don't need to know I
know that a fire door costs 300 quid I
know that a partition wall can cost
about thousand pounds so I know all this
sort of stuff I know that to skim a
house a standard sort of three-bedroom
house to skim it it's gonna cost by a
hundred quid painting decorations about
sixteen and seventeen under pound and
you get to know the familiar is it you
get through that familiarizes there with
costs and it just does depend on how how
what sort of label you want to put into
it so for instance if you want to go
really really high end the the actual
cost price of the products will be more
so the kitchen will be more expensive
than our suitable but yeah okay kitchen
so I wouldn't it's a ruler for it's our
every problem is different it really is
it depends what he's doing and it well I
hope that really answers
it doesn't it probably waffled but I'll
see you in two weeks melon I mean it
probably waffle does that like it is in
I yeah yeah okay watch yourself as it's
just just a terrified I can be in it
okay okay Kyle gin
I like gin I've heard is it is all those
that kid mmm will go Jim have a virgin
Kyle gin is rent around HMO all it's
cracked up to be
I'm very interested in the strategy was
willing if you guys I need top tips or
anything to avoid when looking at renter
and deals love the show and your
knowledge could you show that you could
share would be great okay what do you
think rent rent
hey I just rent when in general what
obviously went to rent is very good
renter HMO that the problem with rent
around HMO is that quite often there's
quite high startup costs yeah I you find
or stuff I would said the best way to do
Reds are HMOs to find existing HMOs
tired landlord yeah where they're where
they're where they're struggling do you
know the problem I found with that is
most landlords who have already got HM
all they want to high rent because they
know that if they rent out they can get
say that let's just say 1500 a month so
when you go into them and try and offer
them a rent rent listen yeah you can
have it by one 800 pound a month and
then by the time you paid the bills and
you know there's not there's not a lot
not a lot money left good money for me I
know I know there is people Michael
those people making good money but
you've just got to know how to find
these properties and negotiate the rent
down with a landlord yeah I've got no
real experience with rent rent hich more
so to everyone I've done to convey what
I've done the only one I've done and I I
actually hand handed it on in the end
because I just didn't want I didn't want
a house loved it
but the only one that I did and it did
make to do very well II I was looking on
rhyming for just normal rental
properties and I noticed one that
clearly used to be an HMO yeah I could I
look I was just like I could see the
fire door I was like okay so we got the
fire doors in and when I went and I went
to view it all we had all the things but
was on for a normal rent because it
obviously given up yeah and so that was
the
in amazement be found on direct what I
did was I searched on spare room and I
found the ad yep from that that property
comes it had been recent so I can't at
the land nor direct I managed to agree a
rental rent deal with him for the for
the price so the last rent to rent hitch
him or I went to see and went to
negotiate in a bit of face I do I know
don't need code as well
and what my something I was just work
that's why the Samson's get hacked all
the time anyway the last rent rent
Hitcher more that I went to see similar
thing found on gumtree and it has
sported the door closers in the
background but he had advertised that's
just a normal single layer property for
rent
and I actually ended the guy agreed to a
rental rent but I managed to then switch
him into doing it as a lease option so
that ended up being a lease option for
me so yeah I'm not I'm not the biggest
fan of live renter and I like to own I
like to yeah but if you follow the money
it's a very good strategy so a very good
right at least option I got with no
money yeah a lot of people making good
money for me so yes it's what is cracked
we got to be aware of the and let know
how to find them or his is a quick one
because we've got quite a few to get
real one get for as fast as we can so on
the eviction Alastair this is a yes or
no answer for you on the expand stare
have you been asked for a face like
thunder or was that your natural resting
face I saw that Adam long hmm I play the
character well I counted fought for you
he hasn't asked our fights life under
but he has been asked to be serious yeah
I was asked to be serious just to not be
smiley in joke he'd be serious and he's
like it's funny because I I fall into
the character of beam of beam em of
being like s very yeah perhaps quite
quite easily because I know I know it's
a yeah good no
so I wasn't asked but I was told to be
serious so I was serious okay you ready
I don't know if you want you're going to
do the face cat in exile I love to smile
I know you stole the they used to having
to do it no that's what David chambers
can't wait for the show well it is here
so no and guess what David
in fact not only is it a it's nearly
finished so you don't have to wait and
listen wait for next week's show maybe
should we just put this question tonight
we know just a tease them that's not
what knows do is do when a person
approaches are selling that house
doesn't happen too often to me I would
you yeah does to me
we're approaches pressure selling their
house how do you get them to believe
you're by the way so figure is true
they'll obviously argue for a higher
price
yeah but it's like anything when you're
buying you want to knock it down when
your cell and you just put up so David
let me ask you this last time you sold
your car did you did you try and sell it
for for the highest possible price you
could get you'd be an idiot if you see
it no and likewise the person buying off
you was trying to get it for as low as
possible
I would show them has only worked it out
I would say look good common ground
this is how I worked out this is the
value I believe it's at however a little
most I can offer is this a little trick
I use when I'm negotiating like below
market value deals and things are is I
walk around with the vendor add up the
cost and add up the costs of everything
so I'm like well you want a hundred
thousand pound for this house it's only
really worth a hundred thousand like
maybe 110 but that kitchen is gonna cost
8 grand
I never tell them trade prices are only
ever tell on retail prices because bear
in mind most people that are selling
houses when you ask them how much as a
kitchen they'll always go buy retail buy
what it would cost being cute come and
fit it so I almost used retail so like
the bathrooms 5 grand and before you
know it there let you start I think yeah
look we were ever that all the work
laughter to get it up to be worth in the
ground I can only offer yourself yeah
you just gotta learn how to negotiate
and how to get them to give you the
price without being unethical good tip
right guys thanks ever so much for
tuning in really do appreciate it we'll
back next Saturday at 7 p.m. you can
listen to us on on the podcasts or Apple
podcast Spotify or obviously come watch
us on YouTube and we will see you next
week so you guys
[Music]
[Applause]